hi everyone my name is Tamra chambers
and this is Tamra's never seen and today
I watched battleship last week I did an
episode of Tamra's never seen but she
had seen it the last time she saw it she
was 6 years old so she was actually just
revisiting it don't that's the only time
I've ever done that and in that episode
I asked whether board game movies were a
thing where there are other board games
that came out are there other board game
movies like operation that just but the
human centipede is I got a resounding
battleship I thought oh cool I'll do
like a Rosie the Riveter like space buns
like weird hairdo space it's not really
anyone I can cosplay as except for the
the girlfriends there's my but she's
very complex this was a bad movie when I
looked it up to rent on Amazon it had
like four and a half out of five stars
and I was baffled it also has Rihanna in
it again baffling anyway so let's just
[Music]
you
dark mysterious music in association
with Hasbro
that will always make me laugh it's kind
of like when we G boards have a Mattel
on the bottom of them it's like well not
as scary when the makers of Barbie also
make your soul summoning device okay
Rihanna's in this cool it's set in
Hawaii cool cool they're contacting
aliens cool cool cool cool cool oh and
then they start talking never mind
turn it off we're done here you need a
job bro no oh hey did you give me this
cupcake bro thanks I sure did bro see
that pretty girl over there don't waste
your wish on her room it's my birthday
and I can waist my wish out whoever I
want
bro we're really going hard in on this
wish thing aren't we it's too birthday
candle wish Oh God get a job so our lead
character Hopper sees this beautiful
girl steals a chicken burrito for her
gets taste and then arrested and I guess
I guess the wish didn't work that's why
things they never tell them you what
about your birthday wish cuz they just
will not come true and I'd say that it
would take more than a chicken burrito
to wound me but I would be lying
so hoppers brother is furious with him
for getting arrested over a chicken
burrito and he says it's time for a new
course of action you're going to the
Navy with me it's time for a game change
battleship rapper so high energy for
such a small video I wrote
he got the girl and his bad at soccer
fun updates for ya
this story is riveting apparently
they've now fallen in love we get some
really fun dialogue between the two some
really fun shots of the girlfriends I
love you do you love me she's very
complexly ready I just have a really
good friend who was in the name
and I wanted to get his take on the
whole situation hi Barney good to talk
to you I just wanted to know if this is
how your time in the Navy was hell Liam
Neeson get out of here what are you
doing it you better than this I have a
very specific set of skills and they are
being completely wasted here
yes that's my Liam Neeson impersonation
and I will thank you to not me you find
out that Liam Neeson is the girlfriend's
father and he doesn't like hopper oh man
me too then Rihanna shows up and she
compares her commanding officer which is
hopper some how I guess he's terrible at
everything and he's literally not how
did he climb the rent okay so anyways
she compares him to Donald Trump and
then Mike Tyson weird weird that's a
weird hopper does something incredibly
stupid and his brother again angry with
him is like they're gonna kick you out
hopper and I just don't get it
you know so much wasted potential where
though where's the potential he's not
done anything I can't find it I can't
find the potential and then also he's so
boring I don't know if it's the writing
I don't know if he's just a little
lackluster but my my mind how can I
resist you mom I never understand
stories like that where they're like you
have so much potential and you're
wasting it you've got a rise above then
obviously they're gonna rise above oh my
gosh we all know it's coming Hopper's
gonna rise above oh right and there's an
alien attack story happening here it's
mostly just about hopper trying to ask
Liam Neeson for Liam Neeson's daughter's
hand in marriage
I am literally never even learned her
name why you got
don't you know I'm human too I'm gonna
marry her anyway marry that girl no
matter what you say
giant alien bombs fly out of the sky
into Hawaii into near Pearl Harbor too
soon I don't know so we see these giant
aliens and let me rephrase that giant
terribly CGI Transformers they show up
there in the ocean they're mean I guess
you can't really tell because it's all
just a giant chaotic mess of bad boring
CGI which is the worst kind of CG yet
it's somewhere in between Garfield and
Birdemic I have a question why is Rianna
here I like her makeup a lot I may have
used a little bit much today but anyway
she's got some bops she's got some good
songs but why is she here in the
battleship movie I think she's actually
one of the better actors in the film but
it's just weird that she's skinnier I
wrote down the first alien fight is
really boring I don't care at all who is
this boy literally who is this sport but
then I realized that the rest of the
movie is that same fight there's not
much break from the jam-packed action
adventure that is battleship and I'm
already 50 minutes in so like how much
longer could there what though oh man
this this movie is 2 hours and 11
minutes
the initial attack like I said just it
just keeps going there's no end in sight
so when all of the excitement hoppers
brother dies and hopper is now in
control of everyone somehow he's nowhere
to be found
he's moping in the bathroom listen I get
it your family member just died
absolutely
but this is not the time nor the place
there are aliens trying to destroy the
entire world something happens in the
bathroom where he's moping and they're
like we need you hopper
Pesek well if not you who literally
anyone else anyone hello kitty that
backpack kid a ghost then they find a
dead alien and they take him inside and
they take off his helmet and show it to
us how science taught us nothing I'm
just gonna start doing stupid things
with my hair out of boredom and anger
there we go
that's nice they find out that the
aliens don't like sunlight because one
of the soldiers one time took his pet
lizard to the beach the lizard didn't
like sunlight
Obama's in the movie very briefly on a
screen don't imagine that he actually
recorded the voice for that but I don't
know this movie's very political
then hopper decides to magically get his
together it's the rise up scene
that we all knew was coming but we still
have 45 minutes left in the movie any
entire rest of the movie is a rise up
scene for hopper a boringly I honestly
don't even know the specific details of
what's happening at this point big fight
big booms big dumb I know people hate it
when I zone out but I am only human and
I'm sorry
hey Barney did you ever have to rise up
to the occasion like Hocker
so hopper and another soldier climb up
this sinking ship and it's a total
Titanic move and you know what's a
better movie than this movie all of them
let's see if we can buy the world
another pretty bad line but even the
movie made fun of that line so solve
their battleships have sunk by this
point and they decide they're gonna pull
out a 70 year old ship the Missouri the
Missouri by the way was the location of
the surrender of the Empire of Japan
which ended world war ii which no you
don't deserve that till they go up to
the missouri and all these vets start
coming out of the Woodworks of the ship
like they've been living there in the
tunnels of the ship they think it's
supposed to be an emotional scene and
actually now that I'm thinking about it
it was pretty emotional because I looked
and there's still 30 minutes of this
movie they've a lot of work to do to get
this 70 year old ship in working
condition
so they roll up their sleeves they put
on some a cdc's thunderstruck they get
to work they accomplish it in like 20
minutes then I looked down at my phone
for like 10 minutes
I'm not even online right now so I was
just scrolling through old photographs
and comparatively it was really riveting
they defeat the aliens hopper gets some
award Liam Neeson was in the movie for
like five minutes I am NOT one to shy
away from action and adventure
I'm not even one to shy away from giant
machine fighting movies which is
definitely the genre and don't fight me
for the pics but this was awful
I give this movie 2 out of 10 hair clips
begrudging need to go take a shower and
wash the shame off of my body from
watching this movie hey Barney do they
were giant hoop earrings in the Navy
there's my butt
[Music]
[Applause]
you